they're the largest snakes on earth
roaming the Amazon
they've eaten goats deer and even
crocodiles
so what would happen if an anaconda
tried to eat you
can an Anaconda really swallow a human
how long would you be traveling through
the snake's body
and has something like this happened
before
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were swallowed by an
anaconda
believe it or not in 2014 someone was
actually dumb enough to attempt this he
was wearing a large bulky suit covered
in Pig's blood
the Anaconda worked for an hour wrapping
its mouth around the head of the suit
but it was ultimately unsuccessful in
swallowing the human whole if it had
been successful how would an anaconda be
able to eat a full-sized adult
so you happen to be wandering in the
Amazon rainforest and you stumble upon
one of these giant anacondas
green anacondas grow up to nine meters
in length and can weigh as much as 225
kilograms
you might think you'd be a tasty meal to
them as a small meal for an anaconda is
about 18 kilograms if they were to
gobble you up it would keep them
satisfied for weeks
but a meal over 45 kilograms like you
might not be what an anaconda is most
interested in
due to how massive you are not to
mention being taller and broader than
most animals it eats you would take too
long to consume
this in turn would leave the Anaconda
vulnerable to Predators for weeks if not
months until it finishes digesting you
but let's say it did want to eat you
what would happen then well before an
anaconda swallows you it would kill you
first an anaconda is a constrictor snake
and it kills by wrapping its body all
around its prey and quickly crushing
them to death with over nine thousand
pounds of pressure it would be a pretty
quick end for you
but we all know that's not how this show
works so let's assume you survive this
and we get to see the entire process
the Anaconda would then widen its jaw to
swallow you whole
you won't have to worry about it chewing
you up into little bits since it only
has fangs used for holding its prey and
luckily as opposed to other snakes the
Anaconda isn't venomous so its fangs
won't poison and paralyze you
but something you will find in the
anaconda's mouth is lots and lots of
saliva
yeah this will be used to moisten you
you know so it's easier for the Anaconda
to slide you down their gullet
so now you're moving down the snake's
esophagus
as with many other animals the muscles
in the esophagus will push you down the
snake's body
the Anaconda also has the ability to
move and bend Its Ribs to crush you even
further and push you down into its
stomach
okay now you're in the anaconda's
don't worry we're still keeping you
alive you know to make this more fun the
anaconda's stomach produces powerful
acids and stomach enzymes that will
dissolve your skin
and then eventually your bones
how fast do these acids work exactly
well an anaconda once dissolved an
alligator's skin in just three days so
your squishy fleshy skin would disappear
pretty quickly
your body would break down even further
As you move through the snake's small
intestine
that's due to the liver and pancreas
secreting even stronger enzymes
everything besides your hair and your
nails would be digested at this point
and even if you were wearing some
magical suit that protected you from the
acid and everything else it would still
be a couple of weeks before you were
unceremoniously pooped out
so it's likely you'd starve although
something like this is incredibly
unlikely
the condos alone
after all they aren't interested in
eating you in most cases as you're just
too big they're really just trying to
defend themselves plus you'd pretty much
die instantly if you tried to mess with
one of these things it can swallow
entire gazelles
Turtles and even lions
this is the Nile crocodile the most
dangerous crocodile in the world
it normally preys on animals found in
Africa but now it's coming for you
how easy would it be for this crocodile
to swallow you
What secrets lie in the crocodile's
stomach
and how would its heart help digest you
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were swallowed by a
crocodile
if you think something like this is
impossible think again crocodile attacks
are more common than shark attacks
and these attacks are responsible for
nearly 1 000 fatalities a year
so what would happen if you were one of
these attacks
would you be able to survive
first let's get to know a little bit
more about this creature who's coming
after you
the Nile crocodile is typically found in
Africa but has also been seen in Florida
in the United States
these crocodiles are incredibly
aggressive and are responsible for over
300 attacks on people every year what
might make it so aggressive is its size
the Nile crocodile can grow up to six
meters long and weigh up to 550
kilograms all this combined makes it the
most dangerous crocodile on Earth
and now it's coming to swallow you whole
you'd first get attacked by the
crocodile somewhere along a river
and it's likely this would happen
between December and May Since that's
the crocodile's breeding season
as you're walking along the river the
crocodile would stalk you waiting for
the perfect opportunity to attack
you probably wouldn't even notice the
Croc and even if you did it might be
hard to get away from it as the Nile
Croc can run up to 18 kilometers per
hour on land and as it caught up to you
it would strike at your leg with its
massive jaw applying 3 500 kilograms of
pressure
this would break your leg preventing you
from getting away
and now the crocodile could drag you
into the river where it likes to do the
rest of its eating
now that you're in the water with the
crocodile biting into your leg it would
begin to roll you around in the water
this is it attempting to disorient and
drown you and at this point you'd be
passed out and now that you're not
moving the Nile Croc would swallow your
body whole
you who would pass through the
crocodile's esophagus and into its
stomach
but wait this is a lot of food and not
every animal would be able to eat
something like this so
how can the crocodile
well the crocodile stomach is unique
that's because these creatures swallow
rocks to help break up their food
and that's why the crocodile didn't need
to chew you
while you're inside the crocodile
stomach you'd be smushed by all these
rocks and with that your body would be
broken up into smaller chunks and rocks
aren't the only thing that would help
the Croc digest you
inside the crocodile's body is a heart
valve that they control with their
nerves
instead of this valve going to the
crocodile's lungs it goes to the stomach
this allows the crocodile to produce 10
times more gastric acid than most other
animals
over the course of a week your body
would be getting crushed up by all these
rocks and you'd be getting dissolved by
all the stomach acid
skin bones hair and all
then the crocodile would poop out your
remains and go hunting for its next
victim
so the next time you're near a swampy
River Watch Out for crocodiles if you're
not careful they can be pretty dangerous
they're the deadliest thing on earth
they suck your blood and spread disease
killing nearly 1 million people each
year
are we talking about vampires Lions
gorillas
actually none of these things were
talking about mosquitoes
are mosquitoes really this deadly
what would happen if they all
disappeared
would Humanity be better off
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we killed all mosquitoes
it may sound unusual that a little bug
could be this deadly but it's true
mosquitoes spread diseases like malaria
yellow fever and the Dengue virus
they do it by biting someone who has a
particular disease and then biting you
and injecting their saliva into your
body
the saliva then enters your bloodstream
causing you to contract whatever virus
or bacteria that the mosquito picked up
and it's not just humans they affect
either animals and farm livestock all
around the world suffer greatly from
mosquitoes just a single bite can be
fatal
so how do we get rid of these bugs well
first we have to figure out exactly how
many mosquitoes there are in the world
that's incredibly difficult to find out
it's estimated that there's seven
trillion of them in Alaska alone
yeah that's right Alaska due to global
warming and ocean temperatures Rising
mosquitoes can live in places like this
and around the world there are trillions
of other mosquitoes
there's a number of ways we could get
rid of them
bats eat mosquitoes without any risks
they can eat 600 mosquitoes in an hour
so if we had enough bats in theory they
could effectively wipe out mosquitoes
all around the world
but then how would we get rid of the
billions of bats in the sky okay maybe
that's not the best idea
another thing we need to understand is
how mosquitoes reproduce
you may think they're sucking our blood
because we taste good and they're hungry
but instead of feeding themselves
they're actually doing it for their
larvae
so if we somehow got rid of all our
blood and wait
yeah that's not gonna work either
instead of these options we may need to
release genetically modified male
mosquitoes
ones that don't bite and can only
produce sterile Offspring it could take
several decades but with enough of our
genetically modified mosquitoes
producing sterile Offspring mosquitoes
would eventually be eradicated
so now that they're gone what would
happen next
well millions of people wouldn't be
getting sick and dying each year you
could enjoy being outside in the summer
without any fear of being bitten and
animals would be much safer as well
that's right not many bad things would
happen if we got rid of all the
mosquitoes
what about the circle of life and all
that
don't mosquitoes contribute to the food
chain sure some birds bats and frogs eat
quite a lot of mosquitoes
but there's still not a hugely
significant part of other creatures
diets and these animals will survive
without mosquitoes and although
mosquitoes do pollinate plants it's not
significant enough to justify keeping
the species alive
but still is getting rid of mosquitoes
the right thing to do after all we would
be getting rid of an entire species
we should keep in mind that there are
thousands of different species of
mosquitoes but only six of them bite us
and spread disease
not only that but there are some
theories that mosquitoes may help to
protect the Amazon rainforest
that's because they're so deadly and
annoying to the people trying to cut
down the rainforest that at times the
bugs actually prevent them from doing so
and let's be real for a second the human
population is growing incredibly fast
maybe mosquitoes are helping us to keep
our population in check wait what am I
saying this would most definitely be a
good thing there would be less disease
fewer people dying and very few negative
consequences
[Music]
um
foreign
no this is not a video about the
fictional 70s Blockbuster Jaws we're
talking about a fish that's much much
smaller than a great white shark
but that's got a bite about two times
greater supposedly its teeth are so
sharp that if it were to bite you you
would only realize it after you saw
blood but what if you were attacked by a
school of these colorful fast-moving
carnivores how much would you feel
and how long would you last
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into a pool full of
piranhas
piranhas have been around for a really
long time fossil evidence puts the
Piranhas ancestors in South America as
far back as 25 million years ago and the
modern piranhas we know and love today
have been here for 1.8 million years so
we've had some time to learn about these
fearsome Little River dwellers
but how much of it is true pay attention
what you're about to see might just save
your life
that piranhas are vicious bloodthirsty
creatures that will tear you apart in
minutes is largely a myth in 1914 former
U.S president Theodore Roosevelt was on
a survey expedition in Brazil where he
witnessed a group of locals tossing a
dead cow into a river that they had
stalked with starving piranhas The
Feeding Frenzy that followed LED
Roosevelt to see piranhas as the
embodiment of evil ferocity he compared
their teeth and their jaws to those of
sharks and claimed that their preferred
prey is usually much larger than
themselves well the story stuck and
naturally like Jaws before it piranha
became a 1978 cult classic spreading
several myths about the fish that a lot
of people still believe
the real truth is that piranhas are
relatively calm fish and most of them
are scavengers that feed on insects
worms and plant material in the rivers
where they live of the few species of
piranha that are attracted to the smell
of blood well they tend to go for prey
that's roughly the same size as them in
fact if you fell into a pool of piranhas
chances are they'd actually be scared of
you piranhas aren't really interested in
humans unless they are extremely hungry
and the human is already dead but it's
not like someone would starve a pack of
piranhas and put them in a pool just to
watch them eat something
at worst you might get nipped and Nod on
a little which is scary enough but you
can rest assured that there has never
been a scientifically proven case of a
human being killed by a piranha sorry
gory be movie lovers but don't let me
spoil all the fun even though you know
the truth now the idea of what piranhas
can do is still terrifying
these fish typically grow up to 50
centimeters long they hunt in packs and
have a bite force that's three times
their body weight this means that
relative to its size a piranha bites
harder than a great white shark harder
than an American alligator harder than a
T-Rex and even harder than a Megalodon
and while it's highly unlikely to happen
if for some reason you were attacked by
a school of piranhas roughly 400 of them
could turn you into a skeleton in about
five minutes
but of course there's always a bigger
fish
something is lurking in the water
do you see it
close calls like this happen with whales
more often than you might expect
and although the people in these videos
Got Away relatively unscathed
there's no denying that they were just
meters away from being a whale's lunch
[Music]
but what would happen if they hadn't
been so lucky
could a human body survive being
swallowed by a whale
has it ever happened before
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were swallowed by a whale
if you've never seen a whale up close
it's hard to comprehend just how
monstrous they can really be
to put it in perspective the blue whale
is the largest animal on the planet
its tongue alone weighs as much as an
elephant and it can fit anywhere between
400 and 500 people in its mouth
but we wouldn't have to worry about one
of these guys swallowing us anytime soon
because their Anatomy makes it nearly
impossible
instead we should be more concerned with
their smaller cousins sperm whales in
1891 reports emerged that a man had been
swallowed by one of these whales and
although he lived to tell the tale he
would never be the same again
according to the story James Bartley was
swallowed when a whale attacked his ship
and he wasn't retrieved until the
following day
when the crew found and killed the whale
they quickly brought it on board their
ship and cut it open revealing an
unconscious but very alive James Bartley
his face and arms were bleached White
and he was blind all thanks to the
stomach acids of the whale
however as the years went by people
started poking holes in this story and
questioned whether James had really been
swallowed by a whale
I mean wouldn't the stomach acids do
more damage than just bleaching his skin
well with the power of science we took a
closer look and we quickly discovered
that if you get swallowed by a whale
coming back out with shiny white skin
would be the least of your worries
okay so the first thing you'd have to
worry about once you were swallowed
would be getting shredded to Pieces by
the sperm whales impressive set of teeth
each tooth is approximately 20
centimeters long
that's about the length of an average
chef knife and whales have anywhere from
40 to 50 of these let's say you're lucky
enough to make it past all of them
next you begin your descent down the
throat Not only would it be dark and
slimy down here but you'd also find it
hard to breathe due to the lack of
oxygen and an increase in methane gas
as the whale's throat muscles
constricted in and out to help Force you
down you'd also start to feel
hydrochloric acid beginning to eat away
at your skin
I know what you're thinking we just got
into this whale and James Bartley's
story already seems pretty fishy
well you're not wrong but what would be
the fun in stopping now
so next you'd be dropped into the first
and largest of the whale's four stomachs
you'd probably be in there for a while
but on the bright side you might have
some light in the form of a
bioluminescent squid or two being noshed
on after your arrival sperm whales love
neon flying squid
you'd better enjoy this brief light show
because after this you'd just be tossed
from one stomach to the next
with the acids breaking down almost all
of your body until you're just a bunch
of Bones being unceremoniously ejected
from the whale's anus
so yeah it's pretty safe to say that
there's no way you could be swallowed
whole by a whale and live to tell the
tale
sorry James you may have been able to
fool people in the 1890s but we're on to
you now
as vast as they are and as monstrous as
they might seem to us whales actually
have no interest in eating humans and if
they could talk they would probably make
a point of telling us that
they're sneaky
they're slimy
and they're hungry for meat
the hagfish or slime eel has earned its
name due to its unique defense mechanism
when they're agitated hagfish can
secrete slime to choke unsuspecting
predators
sharks fall prey to their gunky Wrath
this makes us wonder what would happen
if you fell into a pool full of them
what makes the hagfish so unique
how does hagfish slime expand so rapidly
and why is the hagfish useful to us
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into a pool of
hagfish
hagfish have been around for hundreds of
millions of years and are the only known
living animal with a skull but no spine
they are also jawless creatures with the
unique ability to absorb nutrients
through their skin
using four sets of teeth on their tongue
hagfish like to burrow inside sea
creatures dead and alive and digest them
over time
their bodies are lined with special
glands that secrete stringy proteins
when the hagfish feels agitated this
slime can expand 10 000 times larger in
under a second making it a lethal
choking hazard to predators
so could you survive in a pool full of
them
many hobbyists are actually turning
their pools into self-sustaining
ecosystems for fish and plants known as
an aquaponic system if you're feeling
adventurous and want to adopt hundreds
of hagfish
you'll need a cold salt water pool to
mimic their natural habitat and enough
dead fish to feed them in the
unfortunate event that you slip and fall
into the pool you might still be okay if
you're close to the surface
as bottom dwellers
they may not even react to you being
there but if you happen to disturb them
the water would start to get very slimy
very quickly making it difficult to swim
the Slime isn't actually sticky but it
is particularly strong it would tangle
around your toes fingers ears and the
crevices of your body if it got in your
mouth and started to expand in your
throat you could choke very quickly and
drown eventually the hagfish would Feast
on your body
it's not exactly a nice way to go
also you might want to be extra careful
if you're driving near trucks full of
hagfish
if
hagfish slime is a mucin like Snot
except that it doesn't dry out
[Music]
can someone give me a tissue please
the music is made up of long fibers like
spider silk which are arranged in small
bundles known as skeins when these
skeins come into contact with seawater
the glue holding them together dissolves
and the Slime expands rapidly
these slime microfibers are stronger
than nylon thinner than human hair and
000 times softer than jello
this makes hagfish slime an
exceptionally useful and environmentally
friendly Fabric in fact it's used to
make safety helmets Kevlar vests and
even airbags and researchers are
investigating whether it could be used
as a hydrogel to hold water in soil for
farming hagfish are also considered a
delicacy in Korean cuisine and are used
in many delicious stir-fry recipes so
maybe if you're careful you could
Harvest them as a business
hippos are large loud and dangerous
they kill 500 people a year in Africa
and their attacks are vicious
so if you're around one keep your guard
up and don't be fooled by its big cute
face well look at this little fellow
that hippo might be hungry
but do hippos eat meat
what warning sign should you watch for
and could a hippo fit your whole body in
its mouth
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were swallowed by a hippo
water loving creatures can grow up to
five meters long and they weigh up to 4
500 kilograms
it takes a lot of energy to carry all
that mass around so these Hungry Hippos
have to eat 35 kilograms of food every
night
luckily they're herbivores for the most
part there have been reports of hippos
eating carry-on but they're rare
humans are definitely not in their diet
but that doesn't mean you can relax
around hippos
they're incredibly aggressive and
there's one warning sign that you should
never ignore
if you see a hippo open its mouth in a
yawn or a laugh you're in trouble
this is a sign that it's going to attack
you think I'm gonna tell you to run
sorry but hippos can charge at up to 30
kilometers per hour
and sometimes there's no warning at all
hippos will often Glide underneath a
small boat flipping it and throwing its
passengers into the water
once you're in the water your chances of
surviving are Slim
but could a hippo swallow you whole
while they are big animals a hippo
wouldn't be able to consume you in one
bite instead you'd feel intense pressure
as the hippo begins to crush your arms
or legs with its teeth
you punch the hippo right in the nose
and it loosens its grip on your body
but although you managed to break free
you're in bad shape
there are huge holes in your side from
its tusks parts of your body are
unrecognizable and you're missing an arm
that arm is still in the hippo's mouth
now while you're being rushed to the
nearest hospital
what happens to your missing limb
hippos have a unique digestive system
they have three stomach Chambers and
they use a method called foregut
fermentation
microbacteria living in hippo stomachs
break down food early in the digestion
process it's a symbiotic relationship
that allows hippos to get the most
nutrients out of tough grasses so after
your arm travels down the hippo's throat
and goes into the first chamber of its
stomach microbacteria would begin to
break down your arms
then your arm would pass on to the true
stomach this is where digestive enzymes
would continue to break it down
later the hippo would fling remnants of
your arm and some grass over the beast's
territory hippos can spread their feces
up to 10 meters around them
this plays an important role in the
rivers and lakes of Africa
by eating and excreting grass hippos add
silicon into Africa's water systems and
that's good because unicellular algae
needs silicon to thrive
the algae produce oxygen and it's a key
part of the food web
hippos are extremely Territorial and
they're obsessive about protecting their
young
so while baby hippos sure are cute you
should always steer clear of them
[Music]
thing you should do if you ever fall
into a pool full of stingrays
they may look super cute but don't let
their friendliness fool you
because they're also carrying a long
venomous serrated Stinger that could
kill you at any moment
so should you swim out of there as fast
as you can
or stay close to the surface of the
water
or should you just dance on the bottom
of the pool
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into a pool of
stingrays
the first thing you need to do when you
find yourself swimming with stingrays is
to keep your feet away from them
one way to do this would be to stay as
close to the surface as possible but
another more fun way would be to do
something called the stingray Shuffle
this method involves carefully standing
in the pool and shuffling your feet
along the bottom in whatever Direction
you wish to go
it may look silly but if you were to try
and walk across the pool you'd risk
kicking or stepping on one of the
Stingrays
and that would be a quick way to meet
their deadly Stinger
what is it about this thin spiny tail
that can be so dangerous
the long sharp spine at the end of a
stingray's tail is known as its Barb
if you were stung by The Stingrays Barb
it would cause serious damage because it
would go into your body smoothly like a
nail
but its serrated edges would tear up
your tissues on the way out
like pulling out a screw
and that's just the beginning
as the serrated edges sink into you the
Stingrays Venom would flow into your
wounds
the Venom is not necessarily fatal but
it does hurt a lot
it's composed of the enzyme's five
nucleotidase and phosphate Easter eggs
and the neurotransmitter serotonin if
you're wondering why I'd even try to
pronounce these three big names for you
it's because they're important
especially the last one
serotonin causes smooth muscle to
severely contract and this is what makes
the Venom so painful
some victims who have been stung in
their feet say that the pain is like
squeezing your foot in a vise and
twisting it so let's try to avoid that
the first thing to keep in mind when you
drop into a pool of stingrays is that
they're naturally docile creatures who
will only attack in self-defense they're
so gentle that in the Cayman Islands
there's even an extremely popular
tourist attraction called Stingray City
where people feed and swim with large
groups of stingrays but even though
these stingrays are friendly and love
being fed they still sting some people
the best way to avoid being stung is to
make sure you don't kick or step on any
of the Stingrays
if a stingray feels threatened it will
flip its tail upwards over its body
striking whatever's in front of it
the stingray doesn't control the release
of its venom only the movement of its
tail
accidentally step on one and get stung
you need to get out of the pool as soon
as you can without getting stung again
[Music]
if the wound is superficial it needs to
be treated right away
pull the stinger out and apply pressure
on the bleeding to encourage the Venom
to come out
it's important to listen to your body
because it is possible to have a
life-threatening allergic reaction to
the Venom if you're sure that you're not
having an allergic reaction use hot
water around 43 to 46 degrees to kill
the Venom and relieve the pain
once the pain has been relieved apply
antibiotic ointment or cream on the
wound and cover it with bandages
if the Barb has punctured your abdomen
chest throat or neck or is completely
gone through a part of your body
do not remove it you need emergency
medical treatment as soon as possible
but if you had just followed our advice
from the beginning you wouldn't have to
worry about any of this
because you would have been able to
avoid getting stuck
stingrays aren't really that dangerous
if you treat them right
jellyfish are some of the most dangerous
creatures in the ocean just touching the
wrong one can lead to a swift death
and now these people are swimming with
millions of them
but how
and what would happen if you chose to
swim with millions of jellyfish
what does a jellyfish sting feel like
is it possible to swim with them and
live to tell the tale
and can peeing on a sting really save
your life
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into a pool full of
jellyfish
the jellyfish's venomous sting is
extremely dangerous
just brushing against a jellyfish can
result in incredible pain
their stinks harm over 150 million
people each year
if you were to jump into a pool full of
jellyfish is there any way you could
avoid their deadly stings
[Music]
as soon as you jumped into the pool full
of jellyfish you'd immediately want to
check your surroundings to see what
you're dealing with
jellyfish come in all shapes and sizes
they range from the lion's mane
jellyfish that's longer than a blue
whale to the moon jellyfish that's just
five centimeters long
kind of cute
many of the jellyfish you might
experience here would move with the
current of the water
after all jellyfish don't have brains so
they don't have much control over their
movement but some species like the box
jellyfish are much more dangerous
these jellyfish are different as they
hunt their prey
but regardless of whether or not this
jellyfish is hunting you jumping into a
pool full of thousands of them would
definitely end up with you getting stuck
and if you get stung regardless of the
type of jellyfish you would immediately
feel a burning or pricking sensation
this sting would eventually turn purple
then start to itch and swell over time
the pain would spread Beyond The Sting
site and reach other parts of your body
but if this is all that happened
you'd be pretty lucky
at this point you could get out of the
pool remove the Tentacles from your skin
and the sting would heal itself over
time you might need some painkillers but
overall You'd Survive
and no don't try to pee on it the water
and sodium in your urine can agitate the
Stinger causing it to spread even more
Venom
but you ending up with just a little
sting is incredibly unlikely in this
scenario especially if you're swimming
with box jellyfish their sting wouldn't
just bring you some pain and irritation
if you were swimming and happened to be
stung by one of these
could make you feel weak drowsy and you
might even start to have muscle spasms
this could easily cause you to drown and
if more jellyfish came to sting you
you'd be feeling incredible pain all
over your body
someone else would need to pull you out
of the water as you'd most likely pass
out at this point and as soon as you got
out of the pool you'd need to
immediately get anti-venom in your
system
that's because a box jellyfish sting
releases a Venom that can stop your
heart in as little as five minutes
and if you didn't get the anti-venom in
time you could die
[Music]
so it's safe to say that swimming with
jellyfish could be incredibly dangerous
but this isn't the only way swimming
with jellyfish has to end up there's a
place in Palau known as Jellyfish lake
that has hundreds of thousands of golden
jellyfish swimming about this species is
completely safe to swim with as their
sting is so mild you might not even
notice it
so if you happen to fall into this lake
with all these jellyfish you'd be
completely fine
in fact it would be a beautiful and
breathtaking experience
if by some stroke of bad luck you happen
to end up in a massive pool filled with
a bunch of sharks here's what you should
do
if you fall into the pool during broad
daylight you might be in luck generally
speaking sharks feed at dusk or during
the night so they'll be less likely to
want to munch on you during the day
once you're in the water though the
first thing you need to do is remain
calm and not make any sudden movements
not easy I know but you're not going to
outswim a shark
so what do you do if one comes right for
you
first let's put shark attacks into
perspective
they are incredibly rare and you're more
likely to get struck by lightning than
to get eaten by a shark
believe it or not the fact that you're a
human is incredibly helpful
you might think it would be easier if
you were a fish so you'd be able to
blend in but that's not the case
you see despite what movies might tell
you sharks don't want to eat you
sharks are wired to eat other fish and
not animals they don't know about
and if you're an average sized human
you're a lot bigger than most sharks
to a lot of them you might look like
something that could hurt them
the only real exception could be a great
white shark they're bigger than humans
and not as likely to be afraid of us
but just like other sharks they're
generally only interested in eating
other fish
marine biologists believe most shark
attacks are from humans appearing as
fish in the water
surfer's leg dangling off their
surfboard might look like a seal to some
sharks especially in Rapid Waters
so as long as you look like a human you
should be okay
but what if they smell your blood even
if they do they may still not eat you
it would be a scent they're not used to
and the Sharks might not be interested
in you
you're more likely to be eaten if the
Sharks hear that you're in pain
you know that a single snake bite can
kill an elephant in just a few hours and
if you're not careful snake venom can
kill you in only 15 minutes
but that's from a venomous bite what if
the Venom was already collected and you
took a swim in a pool full of the stuff
what would swimming and Venom be like
how would snake venom affect your body
and could this actually be good for you
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into a pool of snake
venom
so how many snakes would it take to fill
a swimming pool with Venom
an average swimming pool has at least
one hundred thousand liters of water in
it on average a venomous snake can
produce anywhere from one to 850
milliliters of venom
so in order to fill up an entire pool
with snake venom it would take hundreds
of thousands of snakes to get the Venom
you'd have to milk the snakes
yep you can actually milk a snake for
its venom
okay now that we have our pool filled
with Venom what would happen once you
jumped in you'd probably notice that
swimming and snake venom isn't very
different from swimming in water
when Venom is in the snake's fangs it's
about as thick as ketchup but once it's
extracted the viscosity lowers
this makes it easier for the Venom to
flow into the prey's bloodstream
so an entire pool full of the stuff
won't feel all that different from
swimming in water
and what about the smell
well it won't really smell like anything
and if you happen to accidentally taste
the Venom it would taste like a somewhat
sweet almost Tangy version of water
but wait
when do you die
I mean this is what if after all
here's a surprise if you were to swim in
snake venom there's a good chance you
wouldn't die
the reason is is that you're swimming in
something that's venomous rather than
poisonous you see poison is something
that can harm you if eaten inhaled or
touched but Venom needs to be injected
into you through a wound
so swimming and Venom wouldn't really do
anything to you
that is unless you have any open wounds
if you did go in this pool with any sort
of cut then you'd be in some big trouble
the Venom would quickly seep into your
veins and would give you a number of
issues mainly blood clotting what was
once liquid is now a thick jelly-like
paste
blood clots would form eventually
clogging your blood vessels which would
then lead to you dying from a stroke or
heart attack but if you're lucky enough
only to get a few drops of Venom in your
bloodstream you might be okay
that is if you manage to find medical
assistance relatively quickly
in the U.S roughly 7 000 people are
bitten by a snake every year of those
people only five end up dying
on average you'd have about 30 to 60
minutes to get some help
once you find it the doctor will give
you an anti-venom treatment and perhaps
a tetanus shot
then you can jump right back in the pool
just make sure you don't have any cuts
on your body this time
but maybe we shouldn't be swimming in
this stuff anyway even if it does no
harm
perhaps it could be used for something
else
scientists are doing research to find
out if snake venom can be used as
medicine such as for Alzheimer's disease
or to reduce tumors
so instead of playing in snake venom or
being afraid of it we could use it for
good
after all snakes are rarely trying to
hurt us and most snake bites come from
people bothering the reptiles
[Music]
sure is lurking in the ocean
it's double the size of a T-Rex
it's gigantic Jaws could crush a car and
now it's on the hunt for you
Megalodon sharks haven't existed for
more than two million years but today
we're bringing these apex predators back
to wreak some havoc
now some people believe Megs never went
extinct instead they're hiding in the
deepest depths of our oceans
the Mariana Trench
well if the Megalodons were still around
that would be the last place you'd find
them
that's because these prehistoric tyrants
hated cold water they preferred the
warmer Waters of the Mediterranean and
the Caribbean
they also loved to explore the coasts of
Australia and California
if these Predators were around today
they might seriously ruin your Beach
vacation
but if they spotted you swimming in the
ocean
they wouldn't just attack right away and
this has to do with your size
Megalodon sharks were gigantic
at least 16 meters in length so they
needed a lot of food
scientists estimate that Megs ate about
1200 kilograms of fish every day
to hit their caloric intake goals they
even dined on sea mammals like whales
and dolphins
so you puny human might not be worth
their attention
unless you were hanging out with a group
of friends now that's a worthier snack
and the Megalodon could devour you and
your friends all in one bite
oh and let me tell you these Predators
had gigantic sharp teeth
each one of the Megalodon's teeth was as
big as your hand and unlike us humans
Megs kept producing new sets of teeth
every week or two
in their lifetime they'd go through up
to 40 000 of them
if they never went extinct you could
find those all over the ocean
you could find some huge carcasses too
but that wouldn't happen all too often
scientists think that megalodons had a
lifespan of up to 100 years
but you know even if humans weren't on
the Megalodons menu
their enormous appetite would hurt us in
other ways
with this huge new predator in the
oceans there'd barely be any fish left
for us
and not because their boats wouldn't
catch anything but because they would
and then megalodons would hunt them down
attack and eat everything in sight
it's not clear why megalodons
disappeared these millions of years ago
but it could be because the oceans got
too cold for them
well now they'd be in for a treat
because our oceans are warming up
thanks climate change
megalodons would Thrive and reproduce
you see more and more of these Predators
showing up
they'd be disrupting our shipping
operations and potentially bringing an
end to the cruise industry
but eventually they might die out once
again after they ate whatever they could
in the ocean and had nothing more to
feed on
these Slytherin creatures can live in
the smallest corners of your home and
the darkest places you don't dare visit
well not anymore because today we're
killing every single snake on earth
how would this snake hunt begin
would we have to invent a bio weapon to
finish the job
and why would things get medieval
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we killed all snakes
the time for war has come
Humanity has decided that the snake's
reign of terror on our planet is over
but what are we up against
well first don't assume these animals
will be easy to take down
these cannibalistic carnivores may not
have ears but can sense sound waves
through their skin to know what's around
them
don't think their poor eyesight will
help you either
while they can't perceive colors and
have fuzzy Vision some can see heat
sources as if they were wearing infrared
goggles
yeah see that flickering tongue it can
pick up odor particles from the air
the muscles in that jaw can open wide
and devour prey larger than them
that could be your fate if you fail
but if you did succeed on your mission
how could this bring back the most
horrible disease ever
there are about 3 400 recorded species
of snakes slithering around Earth
according to the World Health
Organization snake bites kill over 100
000 people every year
so how are you going to take those
numbers down to zero
well to start you'll need to visit the
warmer regions of the planet
you'll also have to search trees Fields
And even underground spaces like sewers
remember these are literally
cold-blooded killers
snakes need a place that allows them to
hunt and regulate their body temperature
so maybe you could freeze them out
yeah well they're more resilient than
you might think
Burmese pythons are an invasive species
that have been found in the Florida
Wilds since the 1980s
after a record cold snap in 2010 these
Predators adapted to the climate and
started breeding like crazy
so the cold air might not work
maybe you could create a bio weapon
instead
snake fungal disease has already been
spreading globally it causes painful
lesions on a snake's skin which can lead
to death
some snakes can shed their skin to get
rid of it but others aren't so lucky
and once it infects one snake it can
easily spread to others nearby so if
humans could distribute this fungus to
every snake on the planet we could wipe
them all out quickly
okay so now these reptilian menaces are
gone for good but did you just Doom the
planet
without snakes eating them rodents birds
and amphibians like frogs would rise in
numbers
and while these animals might be happy
for the moment that feeling would be
short-lived
that's because they would all be
competing for the same resources to feed
eventually creating a scarcity of food
for all of them
and if you're a farmer you'd have to
deal with an increased rodent population
on your land you'd have to use more
pesticides to fight for your crops and
as a consumer you'd have to pay more
money for your groceries because the
same food would now cost more to produce
but the biggest price you'll pay won't
be at the register well the rodents
scurrying around could spread diseases
across the globe you might even see a
Resurgence of the bubonic plague
yeah the plague could come back and in a
big way
and snakes weren't even on the top of
the food chain either
boars mongooses and birds of prey like
owls and Eagles depend on snakes for
their diet if you killed every snake
many of these species would decline in
numbers some might even become extinct
not to mention humans rely on snake
venom for medicinal purposes potential
treatments for diabetes and cancer have
been derived from it with no further
access to snake venom we could endanger
even more human life
like all things in nature snakes have
their place among us and that place is
not near me so keep your distance
but is every animal the same
what if we killed all ticks instead
well keep watching because that's a
story
for another
what if
they're the largest snakes on earth
roaming the Amazon
they've eaten goats deer and even
crocodiles
so what would happen if an anaconda
tried to eat you
can an Anaconda really swallow a human
how long would you be traveling through
the snake's body
and has something like this happened
before
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were swallowed by an
anaconda
believe it or not in 2014 someone was
actually dumb enough to attempt this he
was wearing a large bulky suit covered
in Pig's blood
the Anaconda worked for an hour wrapping
its mouth around the head of the suit
but it was ultimately unsuccessful in
swallowing the human whole
if it had been successful how would an
anaconda be able to eat a full-sized
adult
so you happen to be wandering in the
Amazon rainforest and you stumble upon
one of these giant anacondas
green anacondas grow up to nine meters
in length and can weigh as much as 225
kilograms
you might think you'd be a tasty